[Music]  stealing some looking looking looking  but down and it's three seconds  [Applause]  second verse 2 the quantity  everyone knew he was going to shoot this  ball that's why he wants it at the end  of games are you kidding me  [Music]  from DeAndre  [Applause]  Oh system over sevens exciting the crowd  [Applause]  here's Harden doctor stop  [Applause]  come on you gotta love this basketball  and that's how you flex on a map he is a  special young man there's no question  about it  Drew's got Alfred and he's got a the  other trail  [Applause]  fortunately a good landing  [Applause]  pick and roll Jana  [Applause]  I've heard of a hook shot that was a  hook dunk sweep snap thing on through  that might be the play of the year so  far  harden trying to get free to choose  Martin up played and they went for the  win the reigning MVP what a performance